conclude by saying that we have observed
a new new boson with a mass of 125.3
plus or minus 0.6 gv
at 4.9 standard deviations
as a layman i would now say
i think we have it
[Applause]
well i would like to add my
congratulations to everybody involved in
this tremendous achievement
for me it's
really an incredible thing that has
happened in my lifetime
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
today is a day
that
will limit infamy if we're listening to
this on july 4th
or thereabouts it is the 10th
anniversary of the announcement
of the discovery of the higgs boson and
today
we are joined by a renowned physicist
and officer i believe at the british
empire a fellow of the royal society
emeritus professor exeter college oxford
university of oxford
uh and that is frank close he's joining
us all the way from oxford
to discuss his phenomenal new book frank
how are you doing today
fine thanks you wrote this wonderful new
book it's called elusive how peter higgs
solved the mystery of mass
and we're going to talk about that we're
going to talk about the book we're going
to talk about peter higgs the mystery
behind them we're going to take some
audience questions i remind folks you
can always submit questions to me on
twitter instagram and on my youtube
channel in the community section that's
where i took a lot of questions uh for
frank and i to discuss later uh but we
always begin
with what you're never supposed to do
frank which is to judge a book by its
cover and we're gonna judge this book by
its cover so we'll show the cover of the
book it's called elusive and i want you
to describe how you came up with the
title what the subtitle means and what
the cover design is meant to evoke in
the mind of the reader
well the title elusive
actually has two meanings it was 48
years
between the original ideas that led to
the
discovery of the boson and its actual
discovery so the boson itself was very
elusive
in the case of peter higgs who's
effectively biography that's set out to
be though as we'll see some things
changed along the way
he also was elusive
at many levels in particular the fact
that
uh by the time the boson was discovered
in 2012 there was a lot of speculation
that he might win the nobel prize that
year but clearly that was too soon
because the 2012 prize was already like
in the cab but the intense media
reaction
showed him what it would really be like
if and when the prize
came his way and the following year
there was a huge amount of speculation
that he was going to win it in fact so
much so i don't think bookmakers would
have taken any wages on it
um
and uh he
disappeared on the day of the
announcement
um he went off to
have lunch at his favorite seafood bar
about three miles away
from his home in edinburgh
and didn't tell his colleagues at all
where he had gone
so the swedish academy who
conventionally contacted the winners to
alert them
before the public announcement is made
at midday
um they couldn't find him and as a
result the whole
announcement was delayed for half an
hour until they decided to go ahead
anyway
so he did a disappearing act on the big
day if you like
and the story is which he confirmed that
uh
after lunch i mean he didn't know
anything at all about this where he was
and he then
came back home he went to an art gallery
to take up some more time
and a lady in a car stopped and said
peter congratulations on the award and
he said what award i mean he was joking
he knew what he was about obviously
um
why he was so elusive is one of the
questions which one might want to think
about but that's the reason for the
title both of them
and when i think about you know peter
higgs it's it's almost impossible not to
decouple kind of the mystique from the
man
um i might have called it you know uh
inscrutable except for the fact that
your title is a better uh a better play
on words because of course the discovery
of the higgs boson eluded
experimentalists uh for you know five
decades uh potentially not uh being very
much in the can at all bookmakers uh but
i wonder you know from the demeanor that
he's known to have
and the kind of mystique around this
discovery which is inscrutable in itself
to describe you have
a gift as you did in your previous book
an anti-matter
for describing very complex subjects in
very uh easy to understand but not
simplified not dumbed down i always hate
that pejorative uh oh you're good at
dumbing it down for no i'm not gonna
dumb it down as feynman said you know um
you should be able to explain it to your
grandmother but he also said when he
when he won the nobel prize a reporter
asked him um you know what did you win
the nobel prize for and then feynman
said if i could explain it to you pal it
wouldn't be worth a nobel prize so let's
not take these guys too seriously but in
the case of higgs
do you think that his inscrutable nature
kind of allowed people to project onto
him whatever they wanted quite unlike
stephen hawking who you talk about in
the book and we'll get to hawking and my
late great friend uh freeman dyson later
on but do you think his inscrutable
character
allows you to basically project onto him
you know this this godlike
characteristic that he kind of took on
and
he least of all seemed to want it
well it's certainly true the last bit if
you said that he least all seemed to
want it
when you read elusive uh you will see
that
uh
the idea of him being a godlike
character is not really one
that i
present
um i mean we're not talking stephen
weinberg here we're not talking stephen
hawking people who did a lot of
frontier work
in their career
uh over many decades in the case of
higgs
as he
said to his student back in 1964 a
student came back from summer vacations
found a note from higgs on his desk
which said
this summer i had the only really good
idea i've ever had
i mean to be fair how many of us could
say we had a good idea anyway but
and indeed that was the only thing in
his physics career that he did and
almost literally so in the sense that i
think he wrote
maybe a dozen papers in his career
of which
the early ones were more on molecular
biology which is where he started off
as a student uh ironically we're working
just down the corridor from rosalind
franklin who
i'm just discovering the structure of
dna and he wrote a paper which actually
was quite significant in that field
along with two collaborators
that was the only time in his whole life
that he wrote a paper with anybody else
so he wrote a dozen papers all by
himself
and of that dozen papers
all but three had no impact at all
almost literally well that's slight
exaggeration one of them had
some interest in in the quantum gravity
community but but by and large um
they they
made no impact of course three of them
were and that is what he is known for
um
so he is an elusive person at many
levels
um what was the start of the question
you were saying about him that you
wanted to know
well i think i i think you basically
answered it i mean his inscrutable
characteristics you know made him kind
of a blank tabla rasa for
those of us to project this this on to
him that's right it was you say you know
how did so much get projected on him i
mean that's an interesting question um
i can only ask answer it really from the
british side um i mean that at least i
can understand
uh
around 1980 when
the momentum
to build what became the largest
electron collider
was certainly growing in the scientific
community and after the superconducting
supercollider
texas got uh stopped effectively by
congress uh the the lhc
if it were to be built would become the
only game in town and this required of
course the cern member states to agree
that this was an expenditure worth doing
and in those days in the uk
the government was very
well
not not necessarily anti-science but
they were really questioning value for
money
and the idea of britain being involved
in what eventually amounted to
effectively the equivalent of 10
billion dollars worth of expenditure
um although it's got to be shared
between like 15 member states and more
it was a thing you know it gave them
pause
and there was a serious possibility that
britain would even withdraw from cern
and so the scientific community not
surprisingly you know very concerned
about this
and then a couple of things happened
one thing actually was leon lederman
writing his book called the god particle
which captured media attention
and the media became interested because
of that aspect of things
in the uk
uh the fortunate thing that happened was
that the minister of science a man
called william waldergrave
perhaps unusually for politicians who in
britain tend to not be very
scientifically cogent
he issued a challenge to the scientific
community to say look um i've heard
about this higgs boson what's it all
about i should just say incidentally
that peter higgs grew up in bristol
which happened to be where waldergrave's
constituency in parliament was so there
was a link there so we issued a
challenge the community to say if you
could describe
the higgs boson on a single sheet of
paper
it might help me
make the case in in government for for
funding of this so um i was one of the
many people who entered this competition
i didn't win it um but i at the start of
it put something similar to what you
said at the start i said that
feynman had made this remark that i
think it was if you can describe the
nobel prize in 30 seconds it's not worth
the nobel prize so i said you know being
asked to describe
profound concepts on a single sheet of
paper um reminds me of five minutes
challenge though i noticed you didn't
specify the font size
but i said to him however i will take up
your challenge on condition that you
will do the same thing for me with
regards to the maastricht treaty
now most of your listeners will not know
what i'm talking about there but these
are the days when britain was
contemplating joining the european union
which we've now disastrously left
um and the maastricht treaty was a huge
incomprehensible document
uh the all the the with all the legalese
in it anyway waldergrave later said to
me very kindly we neither won each
other's challenge i think was how he put
it but so higgs became sort of known
by name at least through that
competition in part
the media picked up that something was
going on
and
came and interviewed him
and
two things i think became clear one was
that although
he was very good at lecturing to
students in a research environment for
example or in university lectures uh he
was not the sort of person who easily
would stand up and present things in in
a public forum
and so uh the idea developed
to
have
him sort of helped in a way
and that's how i got involved later
which was um that
the idea was that i would go on stage
with him and interview him if you like
help him bring the story out
um and we did half a dozen of those over
a period of uh two or three years which
actually spanned the
the time before
the bozon was discovered
then i happened to be with him
immediately before the announcement at
cern then i interviewed him again a
month or so afterwards and a year
afterwards so through this series of
interviews i began to
get a sense of how he personally had
felt
about the original idea
what then became of it waiting 48 years
to see the whole thing happen
and so forth
and at some point along this route i
thought you know this is something that
some point i should write about because
i'm living through history
and
peter higgs is not the sort of person
easily
who would present it himself and this is
the sort of thing i've always enjoyed
doing so that's probably when the idea
became
grew up right but the question that
stuck with me which really is the
question you opened at the start why was
it that higgs became such a
sort of well-known
character
and i think at a certain level it's
probably just the
the mundane nature of his name i mean
if it had been weinberg or einstein or
rutherford that's the sort of names that
scientists have
but higgs is a
sort of name
in britain it's like like like a yeoman
a person of the earth almost like
symbolizes the common person right and
i i'm sure that a psychological level if
somebody called higgs can do this
so can you that sort of feeling so yeah
a amount of people in that strange way
and you point out although we had some
twitter kind of uh controversy which is
not at all rare uh that's the only
particle named after a person and then
someone said well no boson comes from uh
the physicist's great indian physicist
bose and so it's not really only anyway
uh we we don't have to get into that but
wonderful well to be fair i think the
the the statement that was made if this
isn't
publicly handed out it's the only single
particle named for a person i mean
bosons look collective as i say like
penguins the more the merrier
that's right
yeah and
i often talk about you know my favorite
particle uh is is not the proton or the
neutron it's the crouton uh but also i
was reminded of the pion which also is a
delicious particle uh but you point out
in this book that hawking was very
doubtful and he of course made a hundred
dollar wager
which your fellow oxfordian is that how
you say it frank oxfordian roxonium
oxonian uh sir roger penrose uh
multi-time guest on the podcast fellow
nobel prize winner with peter higgs uh
he told me the safest thing in your life
to do is to make a bet with stephen
hawking because no matter what uh you
would either be right the first time or
give him enough time and stephen would
change his mind
stephen made a bet and you describe it
uh in such uh wonderful prose this this
book is a book written for physicists as
well as non-physicists and i say it's
written for physicists because you for
the first time in really my memory you
dissect um three papers at great length
uh not not in the audiobook which i
listen to which has this mellifluous
voice uh read by a wonderful reader not
not frank although you have a wonderful
voice too frank but but at any rate um
the audiobook is lovely but the
audiobook doesn't cover the uh the
treatment of the papers that higgs wrote
the two papers famous papers that higgs
wrote and i believe another one by
ginsburg
and uh it was kind of a precursor about
the
nambu goes on goldstone bozon we'll get
to that all but this is all to say that
frank uh gives plenty of a red meat i
shouldn't say that uh because i know
there's a lot of vegan there's plenty of
rich tofu to digest for physicists
because what you do is you walk the
reader through
the papers that led to this prize and i
think very few although with the
exception of oxonian uh sir roger
penrose he basically won his nobel prize
for this his wonderful paper on the on
the properties of black holes with his
uh characteristic diagrams and so forth
as well as a lifetime of contributions
to mathematical physics but
this is all to say that this is a book
for scientists too and and my audience
is the most brilliant in the known
universe and so for those of you who are
technically minded you'll really enjoy
the pedagogical
approach that professor close does
provide to dissect these monumental
papers in a way that is satisfying
understandable to the expert this is not
really written that the appendices are
not written for the lay audience the
rest of the 260 pages or so are written
for the lay audience and it is a delight
to read it starts with peter's early
years goes through his biology training
you meet all these people that have won
and lost nobel prizes like rosalind
franklin but you also come to a section
where he's interacting with the first
guest ever on the podcast which was
freeman dyson and freeman was a great
friend he used to spend his summers here
in la jolla there's winters here in la
jolla uh god knows you wouldn't want to
leave princeton uh in the in the middle
of the glorious summer but uh but
there's a chapter where you go into a
really um kind of pivotal moment in in
peter's life in in peter higgs life
where he meets with freeman and he gets
his invitation to travel up the coast
from north carolina i believe bryce
dewitt too
all the way up to the institute for
advanced study talk about the impact of
freeman dyson i miss him terribly and i
know that you knew him but talk about
the impact of that chance encounter with
a peer but really someone who is
regarded as almost otherworldly and not
just for his dyson spheres talk about
the import of uh freeman dyson on the
higgs story
well
i'll just start actually by saying the
the first time that i met freeman dyson
it was in the days when he had written
that wonderful book called disturbing
the universe
and he and i met in adelaide australia
where we had gone
as part of celebrations for the
centenary of bragg the younger being
made professor
and
he and i and paul davis
gave three popular talks on three
successive days i happen to be the first
day
um paul ii and freeman dyson iii we gave
these talks in a huge hall
um which probably could have held 500
people so you know
my talk i was very
proud when i saw maybe three or four
hundred people there and paul davies
likewise but when freeman came to give
his talk not only was the hall
completely full but the corridors were
filled with students all trying to get
in and it turned out in part obviously
this is part because it was freeman
dyson but the university had they had
made a typo
in the title of his talk and it had been
put out as disturbing the university
which he would also do on occasion tommy
but but to be fair you know freeman was
a revolutionary thinker but yes you are
um but yes so
this where freeman enters this story i
suppose it is in two parts so he he
doesn't appear in the first part i mean
he in 1947 i guess it was
was key in my opinion
to really identifying
why it was possible to renormalize
that's the big word for make viable a a
quantum theory of quantum electron
dynamics
for which he never shared in the prize
which is one of the great missing prizes
um and along the way
um at that time
schwinger who did share one of the
prizes uh
convinced everybody that a key part of
the renormalization viability process
was that photons the carrier of
electromagnetic forces have no mass
we put that on one side we can come back
to that later um so freeman was in there
in the start
um by
1960s he was at the institute in
princeton
and um
peter higgs with the 1964
is the year that everybody thinks was
the year when it all happened and that
is indeed the the time when higgs and
broughton angler and growling harden and
kibble and others were sort of stumbling
on what became known as the what i call
the mass mechanism
not the heat mechanism the mass
mechanism
but it was two years later in 1966
where
in my judgment the key paper
the one that higgs wrote in which it
included the what's now called the higgs
boson and in particular gave the quantum
amplitudes for its decay into various
processes
which turned out to be key to its
eventual discovery he wrote that while
he was on sabbatical at the university
of north carolina in chapel hill
and um
he he worked on that
i think it's fair to say and probably we
can discuss this also i don't think i
mean as of 1964 apart from a handful of
people nobody took much notice at all
right about this
um so we move on to 1966 and uh what
peter
told me
uh was
that
he was worried i mean people i think
probably among this group of small group
of experts questions about how solid the
arguments really were and so forth there
were subtle questions of which gauge you
did the calculations and so forth and so
higgs planned to write
a
strong mathematical big paper
which would establish the theoretical
foundations of the whole structure and
that's what he set out to do
in chapel hill
um and in the course of that and this is
the biggest surprise that i probably had
in the whole the research of the of this
is that he said that
he set out to answer all these
criticisms he produced a very
mathematical manuscript about gauging
variance and how it works in different
ways and then thought that this is going
to be very impenetrable and so he
thought he ought to add some sort of
simple pedagogic examples
and so section three in that paper which
discusses the decays of
the scale of ozone the massive scale of
ozone which i'll call the higgs boson
here in particular into two massive
vector bosons
such as we now know the w and z bosons
are but they were not known at that time
he included that in the paper and by
chance that
50 years later turns out to be key
a fact which he was totally unprepared
for unaware of but anyway he he wrote
the paper
and uh
freeman dyson
was on the mailing list peter higgs was
visiting bryce de witz group in north
carolina which really specialized in
quantum gravity right the higgs had been
interested in gravity that's why he'd
been invited by dewitt to visit but by
the time
of 66 came round higgs had got interest
in
these things
so bryce dewitt's mailing list sends out
pre-prints and freeman dyson who's
interested in everything uh read this
and
said to peter if you're up in the
northeast come by the institute and so
that moment he said to me that was the
first indication that i had that what i
was doing was of interest because when i
mean dyson is one of the or was
one of the
sharpest and clearest sounding boards
for what is a good idea and i think to
be fair that were dying to suddenly call
me up the institute that way i think ah
so what i am doing has some interest so
that was the first clue for higgs and he
went up there
and the actual occasion was interesting
because
the way it worked at princeton was that
um
the
although the people at the institute
had no formal responsibilities for
teaching or
so forth they would if you like left
their own devices nonetheless they had
to satisfy their peers that what they
were doing was worthwhile and they had
what they called the shotgun seminar
so
the invited speaker on this case higgs
would give their seminar after t
but before tea whoever was the unlucky
winner of the unlucky dip and said it's
your turn this week would give us
spontaneous
uh talk and on this particular occasion
it happened to be friedman dyson who
gave
that talk which was actually about the
structure of matter and subtle questions
and we're talking 1966 here
you know what's the difference between a
solid and a gas or the solid and the
liquid and so forth and phase
transitions
um and so then they came to the tea
break
and peter's going to give the talk
afterwards with all these distinguished
people there and during the tea break
somebody comes up to him who's read a
paper
saying oh i think
you're wrong you know there's three very
distinguished people have pointed out a
big error in your work
which was not the thing you want to hear
when you're going to give a seminar but
anyway it turned out during the talk
that he convinced the audience and uh
and freeman dyson was i think
very
important for
providing that first piece of confidence
that this was something that meant
something
yeah and all young scientists need that
kind of um you know recognition or uh
even just encouragement from colleagues
from mentors and and friends uh i was
struck kind of by the lack of in um
sort of
you know
including his you know sort of i don't
say reclusiveness i think that gives a
negative connotation but the inscrutable
nature of him i i don't recall any real
discussions of his
students or his academic family lineage
his ancestry uh either before or after
um was he known as a teacher i know you
you talk a lot about in the book how he
was kind of this um really just not
disheveled but but a little bit out of
place talking with journalists and and
initially trying to do it give a talk to
a public or press audience and basically
launching into a physics lecture um what
was he like as a teacher did he have
students does he have students um what
was he like as an educator
i'm told
the students loved him he was a great
pedagogue i mean basically he
in this i mean he's 93 now so he's no
longer
active at all
but he was i would think
to say caricature isn't not a fair
description but but he symbolized what
you might call the classical
old english pedagogue scholar
um who would spend their life
studying books and then lecturing about
them um and and that was certainly the
style um with regards to students uh
there was one particular student that he
had david wallace who i mentioned in the
book who
is actually an exact contemporary of
mine
he and
david was an undergraduate student at
edinburgh university where peter
happened to be i was an undergraduate
student in saint andrews which is also
in scotland
and at the end of my time um i
fortunately won a scholarship to go to
oxford to do my phd
and had david wallace
gone in for that scholarship he would
have gone to oxford not me and the whole
of the world would have been different
but there we are david stayed at
edinburgh
and he later became a very distinguished
physicist in condensed matter in his own
right um but he was a student of peter
higgs and we're now talking uh his first
year
1967 to eight i guess um
and uh in the first year peter's style
as in many places was to give
prospective research students a reading
list to go away and look for so david
recalled how he was in the library and
he saw a paper by stephen weinberg
this was the paper that weinberg wrote
in 1967
called a model of leptons
in which
he
to some degree uh independently
rediscovered what became
the su-2 across u1 standard model with
two massive bosons the w and the zed in
there
and he was aware of the
the the mass mechanism because he had
talked to peter higgs uh in a mutual
visit to brookhaven the year before
um
and wallace saw this paper
and he was very excited by it because he
noticed that the peter higgs was
prominently cited in this and it all
seemed to be built around that something
that peter higgs had done
and at the end of this paper
weinberg speculated
that
using this mass mechanism it might be
possible to make a viable theory of what
we now call quantum flavor dynamics
now
wallace then ran upstairs and showed
this paper to peter higgs
and said this looks a great problem to
work on to
prove
whether or not this model is indeed
renormalizable and hinks basically
um thought this was not a good idea and
i think that was a wise judgment
and david actually now
agrees with that because
look historically what actually happened
stephen weinberg gave a similar problem
uh weinberg told me this when i was
researching the infinity puzzle about 12
years ago he
gave to a problem the problem to a
student uh to test the
re-normalizability
and after a
period of time it became clear this was
not going to be feasible the student
just couldn't get through it and
weinberg said to me that he also was
never able to do it
because the techniques that eventually
were used were
called
he was not not happy with so if you have
something that weiner himself was not
able to do
and indeed was only eventually done by
herrhod toft
uh in a tour de force in his thesis in
71
in part building upon the fact that
teeny development had built already a
huge infrastructure um i think it was
just as well that david wallace didn't
set out to try and prove the
renormalizability
of this theory so that was one of
higgs's probably well higgs said that
that was the smartest student that came
through edinburgh in the whole of his
time there and he felt that even
somebody like that it would not have
been a good idea to give that as a
problem
yeah that's uh kind of you judge your
your students you know maybe early on
when they are naive and new to the
subject although i guess in the uh and
the us it's different than the way
things are in the uk
uh but you know it's it does seem like
he's he has had this great influence and
and yet like feynman who also famously
turned down accolades and honors uh such
as uh he never would accept fine would
never accept a
an honorary degree because he felt that
demeaned the uh prestige and the and the
the fact that people who would actually
earn the degree earned it and so uh
peter turned down knighthood at least
once right um as you talk about
and you know i wonder he really
seems to be you know unlike uh unlike
many people
maybe even yours truly aspired to it at
one point in my career almost obsessed
about it um
now that maybe the bloom is off the road
somewhat for me having having studied it
in more detail but um with him
do you think you know
all the legend all the lore you recount
the book him not being available for the
phone call going to a seaside restaurant
and
uh and and as you discussed do you think
that you know ultimately
this uh this decades-long quest do you
think that ultimately you know where do
you feel like the nobel prize actually
figured
into his thinking his motivation if at
all i i i don't think there's any
motivation for nobel prize when he did
what he did um
the analogy that i give to
what he actually did was like gary
player the famous occasion when
supposedly gary player after holding
this almost impossible put on the golf
course
somebody supposedly said oh that was
lucky gary and gary says yes and the
more i practice the luckier i become i
mean in the case of of higgs when you
look back over this whole saga and
career um you could say he was lucky
um well yes
he was but
it's more
than just luck you have to be ready i
mean being in the right place at the
right time is lucky but you have to be
able to take advantage of it and in his
particular case um to draw the gary
player analogy he had been doing the
work for the previous two or three years
he had really been trying to understand
really what's going on with this
business called gauge invariants and the
link if any that it had to the photon
being massless or not um and so by the
time you know 64 wound round he probably
understood that as deeply as anybody
probably other than julian schwinger who
had started the whole whole saga so he
was in the right position by chance when
a paper by walter gilbert uh came
through the males or in the in the
fizzrev um which uh
uh said it was impossible to get around
there was a technical blockage in theory
called the goldstone film but it was
possible to get around this technical it
would
it was possible to get around this
technical blockage
in a non-relativistic world because of
certain technical features but those
technical features were not present in a
relativistic world and therefore it
would not be possible to do it and higgs
because of the reading he'd been doing
knew a particular example in the
relativistic world which contradicted
gilbert's statement
and so now it was a matter of really
understanding what gilbert was talking
about because he had a counter-example
to this so that he could then
write the first paper to show that there
was potentially a way through this
blockage
and so he was in the right place at the
right time and well prepared um so that
was where the luck came in if
that was lucky
so yeah when i think about uh you know
this this you know contribution i was
reminded and i think you might have even
mentioned it at one point in the book
um you know there was a quote by alan
sandage back in the 60s and 70s about
cosmology as a search for two numbers uh
namely the hubble constant and the
deceleration constant what they thought
was a deceleration constant then
discovered by passed into the impossible
guest brian schmidt and adam reese along
with saul permader winners of the 2011
nobel prize to be a negative
deceleration aka acceleration uh but but
the quip by sanders of the search for
two numbers um kind of echoes in this
book is the search for one number which
is the the
um the mass of the higgs and can you
explain why a heavier particle like the
w and z sorry like the top quark and
other uh elementary particles why were
those discovered earlier prior to the
higgs is there a reason that the lay
audience can contemplate and understand
why that occurred out of order sort of
in in terms of energy scales
well i mean going back to the 64 when it
all begins
um it's probably sobering to recall how
relatively primitive particle physics
was at that time
um i mean the biggest accelerator uh in
the world was
was well in the electron world was
probably at stanford in california a two
mile long linear accelerator which was
powerful enough to probe inside the
proton and reveal the quarks
the quarks incidentally were first
proposed in 1964. it was a big week big
year 64. i think the big bang theory was
sort of established in 64 as well
um
so
in brookhaven
uh and cern
they had
the largest proton accelerators which
were a few hundred meters probably in
diameter
and the energy scale they could reach
was probably a few tens
of gv the most massive particle that was
known at the time
was
maybe no more than twice the mass of the
proton to 2gv
so into this scenario you have the first
emergence of ideas that there might be
things which we now call w and z bosons
the carriers of the the weak force
whose masses were
calculated theoretically to be of the
order of 80 or 90 gev
and the first person really to get to
that stage was shelley glashau in a
paper in 1961 which was by and large
ignored for a couple of reasons from the
experimenter's point of view
who is going to be interested in
producing particles of 80 or 90 gev i
mean
they were clearly a theorist's fantasy
you don't have things
40 50 times
heavier than anything we can do at the
present time from the theorists point of
view they thought well this is a waste
of time because this theory is all very
well but it can't work and it can't work
because we know from schwinger and dyson
and all that renormalization stuff that
the reason why quantum electrodynamics
is viable is because the photon has no
mass
and the theory of the weak force would
be complete nonsense because for that
the w and z have a mass therefore what's
the point
but we now know of course because of the
mass mechanism that you can get around
that but that was still for the future
so the w and z
um
i think the belief that we're on the
right track came in 71 i mentioned how
at and velman showed that
thanks to the mass mechanism is indeed
possible to create a viable theory you
can start off pretending that w and z
have got no mass like a photon use the
mass mechanism they get the mass but
everything works nicely at which point
people realize there may be something to
this
and that is what inspired in particular
carlo rubia who was
then a senior scientist at cern and
harvard later became dg at cern to
propose
converting one of the big proton
accelerators to a collider of protons
and antiprotons
because in the annihilation of a proton
and its antimatter counterpart there
could be enough energy that if you were
lucky you could produce w or z bosons
and in 83 84 1983 84
the w and z were found with just the
right masses so now it was clear that
definitely we were on the right track
and 1890 gv was still huge but it was
now within range
that then gave enough confidence to
build at cern
the large electron positron lep collider
which was the 27 kilometer ring
with electrons going one way positrons
the other annihilated head-on
so that they produce in a small region
of space
90 gv of energy and if you're lucky that
will occasionally materialize as a 90 gv
massive zed
and that way you're able to study this
i think 10 million zeds were produced
over the next decade or so
and by measuring their properties very
precisely
things began to be noticed first of all
that the theory worked because the
properties would describe perfectly
about one percent
but once you got more precise
you started noticing subtle deviations
now at that time um
the quarks that have been discovered
um five of what we now know six parts
were known the bottom quark with a mass
of only four gev was the heaviest then
known
people suspected that there needed to be
a sixth quark to complete the pattern
called the top quark
and the deviations in the
properties of the zed
showed by quantum
field theory that the top quark is there
affecting things in the background if
you like because of quantum uncertainty
and the deviations could be understood
if the top quark was
somewhere 150 to 200 gv in mass
at fermilab
they then in the 90s
had the biggest proton accelerator
in the world by then which was
approaching an energy of up to about a
tev a thousand gev
um about one tenth of the size of the
present large hadron collider
and in those experiments they were able
to produce the top quark and found its
mass what is it 185 or something like
that
you could then put this determined mass
back into the calculations and you found
that the part of one in a thousand or so
there was still a deviation
which was the first clue that there's a
higgs out there probably with a mass
somewhere between 110 and 130
um
and so that is what led to the large
hadron collider at which the the
particles eventually found at 125 bang
in so along the story it's really been
quantum field theory and quantum
uncertainty all the time that you're
able to look across the horizon of
energy to see what lies beyond thanks to
quantum uncertainty but then you need a
bigger
energy source to be able to actually get
there and see the thing for real
yeah exactly and i think you know if we
look at the
you know discovery and i think you know
now we should probably pivot to the
you know the mastodon in the room as as
roger likes to say you know which is the
the nobel prize itself and why it's
caused so much you know controversy on
one hand and um an elation on the other
hand
but i think let's start with you know
the search itself before we pivot to
issues of credit and etcetera and you're
very careful in the book to talk about
the the mass mechanism and and really
peter himself you know for a long time
was was very much um you know kind of i
wouldn't say embarrassed but he didn't
like the name you know really being
associated with him and he even referred
to it by this ungainly you know seven
letter nickname including my late great
uh professor at brown university jerry
gorelnick
and uh and and his colleagues and past
guest carl hagan on the podcast uh
including their initials but let's let's
talk a little bit about the
experimentalists who are so key to this
and the fact that none of them really
participated in the
in the nobel prize itself some felt that
was a slight especially since there was
an open quote-unquote slot uh in the
nobel prize list of three winners which
is uh i've talked about is one of the uh
the second most cruel aspect of the
nobel prize perhaps but uh second only
to the posthumous elimination of of
nobel prize winners but anyway talk
about what was the reaction i mean you
were at cern you you participated in
many of the events surrounding it um and
subsequent to it and now we're at the
10th anniversary as we say july 4th 2022
is the 10th anniversary of the
announcement talk about the the you know
kind of uh the i don't say lack of
recognition obviously it was key but but
how did the entire the experimentalists
take it i i've heard privately that some
were very much miffed and you know they
don't want to go on the record because
of course you know it's such a nice
story as it is uh but talk about the
impact of the experimentalists not
really receiving the recognition that
people like rubia who you talk about in
the book received you know uniquely so
uh and it's been 10 years probably not
going to happen right so talk about that
that impact on experimental physics
in general and why there was this
dichotomy perhaps
well i mean if you're asking about
should the experimenters have shared the
nobel prize or what have you i mean
that's a question you have to ask the
nobel committee as to why they made the
decisions that they made don't take my
phone calls anymore i see okay i mean i
can tell you what i
suggested back in
2012 when the boson had finally been
discovered
um and there was already the question
about uh
where's the nobel prize going to go and
there already seemed to be a general
sort of agreement well
because they discovered higgs boson then
higgs is going to be in there and there
are three places and where's it all
going to go and so forth um and
by that stage robert brout who was one
of the
co-discoverers of the mechanism with
angler had died
and so
there was sort of
on the theory side of the question well
there's two parts of this
the experimental discovery
or even further back the design and
construction of the machine so there's
an engineering issue there's a physics
experiment issue and there's a
theoretical issue
um
i
argued on the theory side that
if it was going to go to theorists
um i saw an opportunity here
that
anglair and brought were the first
people to publish the mass mechanism
and anglais was the only survivor there
then higgs was the only person among all
of these who drew any attention to a
massive bosom and by accident maybe had
given the indication of how to identify
where it produced which left one spot
and i argued that that should go to tom
kibble
for two reasons one i mean he was the
third party on a paper that wrote with
garlic and hargan which was published
two months after this so i mean
yes they did this independently but the
bad luck is you know you don't get
prizes for coming in second that's the
the regrettable reality
but he'd been involved with that but in
my mind i think the most singular theory
contribution in the whole was actually
in 1967
in a paper that tom kibble wrote on his
own
[Music]
which showed how to keep the photon
massless while giving masses to these
other particles
and that might sound a bit right but
it's not that up to that stage what all
of the work had been doing was highly
theoretical it was showing how to make a
mass mechanism in principle and higgs
had shown that if nature uses this the
test is that there will be this boson
with certain characters but precisely
how nature used this and where and how
to build a theory
it was kibble in 67 who showed how to do
that and it was kibble's paper
that stimulated stephen weinberg
to write his model of leptons and he
cites kibble very prominently in that i
also know that kibble also inspired
salam to the importance of this whole
business which explains why it was when
i was a student
before i knew all about this stuff and
it was still very fresh salam always
referred to it as the higgs kibble
mechanism
so kibble i think was singular so i
wanted him to be the third of that
and i s um i was at a dinner on kibble's
80th birthday
and
i think um
well i remember who it was but somebody
from the physics nobel committee was at
that din and
and he had read the infinity puzzle book
and he said to me um
well frank he said sir
how do you think we should deal with
this
and so i said uh well i said i've made a
lot of argument in my book he's i have
read your book from cover to cover i
thought well no pressure there then
i then said i said look i said this is
my solution um there's just been
announced um a new i think it's called
the queen elizabeth prize for
engineering which has designs on being
an engineering analog
in stature of the nobel prize and i said
i think the queen elizabeth prize
should be awarded to
lynn evans on whoever on behalf of the
the actual facility the machine that
they have built
the physics prize should be awarded in
some combination to the experiments and
and or or cern for the discovery that
they've made
and that angler as the survivor higgs
and kibble should be awarded the prize
for chemistry
and that wasn't a facetious remark
because
my regard is that the
application of everything they did
really explains why we have structure
and indeed rutherford got the prize for
chemistry so anyway the nobel guy said
to me if that happens frank i will
nominate you for the peace prize
uh so there's no shortage of controversy
you know surrounding any nobel prize but
i think in this case because there were
so many you know that rightfully could
have claimed you know paternity for it
uh and also because higgs seemed to shy
away from it uh that you know my as i
said my late grade teacher jerry
gerlnick who with hagen and kibble were
were intimately involved and did
uh actually have a massless boson that
later became
uh you know swallowed up and and did
take on mass i think you know there
there is rightfully kind of you know
this this claim and and i of course now
feel like the nobel prize does
almost more harm than good but maybe not
quite
uh don't tell the 12 nobel prize winners
that have been on
i'm not sure there is really any big
controversy over
having made the decision to award it to
theorists um i think i understand why it
was awarded the way it was but the fact
that the third spot was left blank the
kibble didn't include the award was
actually probably a profound recognition
that although robert brought was now
dead then you can't award prizes to see
posthumously he was recognized in fact
he was mentioned several times in the
oration at stockholm so i sort of feel
that he was there in absentia as the
third place
um but beyond that
who else in theory are you realistically
expecting that it should go to within a
constraint of three people and with all
due respect to relic hard and even tom
kibble um there isn't anybody else
there's two russian guys whose name for
the moment escapes me who were students
um was it polly arkhoff and migdal was
it right that
actually had discovered the mass
mechanism
in russia
back in 63
and have been talked out of it by senior
professors
and indeed jeffrey goldstone
whose paper on the massless bozon
problem is what stimulated the whole
business
and the solution of the whole business
of course was you add maxwell's
equations in include electromagnetism
well
jeffrey had also done that back in 61. i
would guess we're talking roughly now
yeah and so i think well as you are very
much aware this whole story i think
really begins
somewhere around 6061 in harvard where
schwinger was having a change of heart
that back in 47
he had proved that
massless photons engage in variants
somehow go together but he had never
been able to prove it totally and he was
beginning to suspect it wasn't in
general true and of course we now know
that it isn't in general true now when i
look back i mean through jerry
growling's history that he was very
intimately linked with guilt in fact was
gilbert his supervisor
i think so
i mean it was clear that um there must
be talk going on you know in in the in
the coffee room at
harvard about um
massive could you could photons have
mass and so forth yeah because i know
around that time gilbert wrote a paper
looking at what might happen when
photons interacted with other particles
and i think if i recall garelnik's
memorandum um there was some sort of
mention of that in his work which got
him started in that direction oh
certainly yeah jeffrey goldstone had
told me when i was researching infinity
puzzle and i mentioned it in in elusive
um that he also when he wrote his
what the work that he did he led to the
goldstone boson he also included
electromagnetism and found that it gave
a master the photon and he mentioned
this to schwinger and in goldstone's
memory schwinder's reaction was
something like well that's sort of
obvious
now it's certainly true that around that
time schwinger wrote a paper where
it was he was clearly questioning
whether his
belief that gauging variance masters
photons was absolute but it wasn't at
all clear that he regarded it as obvious
that you could give matters in any event
it seems that schwinger's reaction was
enough to
make jeffrey goldstone think well i'll i
won't do that i'll focus on the big
problem which was this
gold stone boson but that's a total
irony you know if true that
goldstone already had the solution to
his own problem but was talked out of it
so the mass mechanism has a long
convoluted history i mean the toft
independently rediscovered it when he
was doing his work in 71.
the boson itself and i challenge anybody
to find a massive scalar boson in any
paper other than the one of higgs
the fact that higgs may have done it by
accident all luck
well how can we ever know but he did
that's right
and of course goldstone is still very
much alive thank you and uh and could
have been considered yeah i feel like he
is this you know he is kind of elusive
in the sense that
is really this this problem now of
course you know is the massless issue
and then and then actually getting the
mass mechanism to work out is really the
key inside so but you know they've given
nobel prizes to wrong ideas like uh like
uh boar at a model and stuff like that
so
it could be a greatest hits award uh you
know so to speak but let's pivot away
from that because i i know we only have
a few more minutes left and i want to
cover a couple of more issues one in the
in the field of cosmology which you no
spoilers involve but we we sort of
dovetailed to it at the end of the book
uh of course my colleagues and i are
looking for
potential signatures of primordial
gravitational radiation which would be
potentially caused by
the uh a so-called scalar uh scalar uh
field called not a boson but a scalar
field called the infoton
that would be present in the early
universe coupling to gravity
in the book you talk about that and that
would be the cmb imprint of so-called
primordial b modes although they're all
alternative models that predict no b
modes and that there is no singularity
and there is no big bang uh the way we
think about it it's more of a cyclic
model that's for another time but
looking at uh the analogies between the
higgs boson and the inflaton can you
talk a little bit about uh how
the future what the future of the higgs
looks like and not only experimentally
because as i understand it you know the
the lhc is is still running they're
gearing up for a new higher luminosity
run 13 tev
there's no real targets right i mean you
you say there is a natural target it's
the planck scale
good luck finding that
we've had james beacham and we've had on
other experimentalists from lhc on atlas
and my colleagues here at cms at uc san
diego but in reality you know there is
no natural target just like there may
not be a natural target for inflation
either how should we handle this
potential existential crisis where you
don't have a good target to go to as you
did with the higgs but uh now kind of
just the refrain that i hear is bigger
is always better uh what do you make of
such claims
well i think in the i mean certainly
it's correct that um i i say that for
50 years um we have
had a fairly clear idea of where we were
trying to get to and how far we had to
go to get there and in fact over the
last uh 30 years it was becoming very
clear that although we thought we were
going to have to have a one tev energy
scale to get to whatever the solution to
electroweak symmetry breaking is uh we
we honed in on 110 gv and indeed found
the higgs 125
but now we don't have any clear marker
like that
there is however one immediate question
i think which
is important which is a big strategic
one i mean
we've found the higgs boson so what
um but this is not just collecting
postage stuff if you stop now it's
collecting postage stamps this is a very
valuable postage stamp but but you know
that wasn't what it is really about
um i mean an analogy that i draw is that
just like fish need water so we need the
higgs field
we don't know what it is we know that it
has no sense of direction or in quantum
sense has is a scalar
we know how much energy it takes to make
it bubble up er into to reveal itself as
bosons
but that's about it
now
what we really want to understand is
how is it that the higgs bosons condense
to make
this field
and the analogy is it's as if some very
bright fish have discovered a molecule
of h2o which has proved that indeed they
do live in water
but what they really want to understand
is how the oceans are formed
and that is like us i mean really we
really want to understand what this
higgs field is because that is what
determines everything we now know
and until we understand what it is it'll
be hard to know how the determination
takes place so i think the first step to
that would be and this is what i think
the new high-intensity experiments that
the lhc will hopefully be doing in the
next few years
to be able to produce two higgs bosons
in a single collision and if you're
lucky enough that those two bosons
interact with each other before you
detect everything we'll start getting
the first information about how higgs
bosons mutually interact and get the
first idea of how this higgs field is
formed
that's the theory side well that's the
experimental side
you mentioned the infoton
and the early inflation i mean i'm now
getting outside my pay grade but i have
this sort of gut feeling
if that's the right metaphor in this day
i'm not into grand unified theories um
but the other sort of gut feeling um
that
isn't it remarkable that we found the
higgs boson actually it seems to be so
simple i mean the the simplest model
that was written down in 1964 seems to
be consistent with everything at the
moment which is something there's one
other place at least that i'm aware of
in quantum field theory that scalars are
wanted and that is what you mentioned
the infoton so the obvious question is
are the infoton and higgs boson one and
the same thing well
insofar as we
the higgs boson as we know it at the
moment certainly not because the
inflaton drove the expansion of the
whole universe so it con it couples very
strongly to gravity and the the boson as
a standard model doesn't do that unless
there is very
massive very massive particles out
waiting to be found and given that the
higgs boson likes to couple to mass the
bigger the better so to speak the
possibility that it might couple through
these
ultra massive things bubbling out of the
vacuum and these have big enough mass to
couple to gravity
sort of like the way that frank the
frank wilcheck pointed to discovering
the heats you know that that
light particles like gluons or photons
can turn into massive topic quarks which
can then couple to the higgs and produce
it likewise if they're
supermassive
stuff
uh that couples the higgs and also comes
to gravity
maybe they are one of the same thing
but so i really do think the big
question in the longer term and how it's
going to be done is a question for the
future experimentalists and funding
agencies and everything else
is i think the idea that the higgs boson
is some sort of placid structures thing
is is as naive as i mean all of history
has been you look carefully you start
seeing things are made of stuff so the
analogy that i would end up with here is
i think we are in profundity
and now i'm just aware rutherford was
back in 1912 or so
when he had discovered the nucleus at
the heart of the atom but all he was
able to tell with his alpha particle
probes was there's a lump of massive
charge there
but what it consisted of he didn't know
and that's where we are with the higgs
field
later
they became aware that it's made of
protons and neutrons and if you're a
science fiction writer and then you
learned you could do things with that
and manipulate the nucleus and such like
i suspect we will find the higgs field
has some structure
and given that the higgs field
ultimately determines not just massive
fundamental particles but why they have
the particular masses they have
there's got to be something going on
there more than we yet know to get to
questions like that
whether or not you would then be able to
manipulate the higgs field and change
stuff
well there's a science fiction story
waiting to be written
well speaking of science fiction we're
going to conclude with what i usually
call the thrilling three or the
fantastic four
uh but but we only have time for one
question and it's from renowned
science fiction but also science
nonfiction author sir arthur c clarke
who is the namesake of the eponymous
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination here at uc san diego which
i'm privileged to be the associate
director thereof
and also the uh the
very quotable
man who gave us the title of this
podcast by saying the following he said
the only way of determining the limits
of the possible is to venture beyond
them into the impossible and i like to
turn that around frank and i ask all my
guests
the following question sort of advice to
your former self
frank if you could go back to 20 year
old 30 year old frank
and give him one word of advice
to give him the courage to go into the
impossible
what would it be
um the same advice i give to the
students right here and now that are
coming through their phds
that there's going to be a time in the
future
when the textbooks will be filled with
stuff
that is yet to be discovered
somebody has to discover
why not you
why not you and frank uh i want to be uh
the first to extend the congratulations
on another phenomenal book uh you're
such a good writer and um and your books
have been uh have been inspirational to
incredible numbers of
scientists and non-scientists alike
you're also a renowned scientist and i
want to thank you for sharing that gift
with the public i have a controversial
belief that we scientists have a moral
obligation to do outreach to the public
let's not get into that now i i don't
want to saddle you with my own
particular peccadillo problems but i
want to thank you
for this wonderful book called elusive
which is how the mystery of missing mass
or how matter gets mass
is
such a delightful story both for the lay
audience but also for we
my fellow physicists who who uh love to
devour uh in some detail maybe not in
our particular field but this is a as a
gift to physicists and to the lay
audience elect frank congratulations and
thank you for going into the impossible
with me and folks stay tuned because i
have the inaugural higgs
chair professor uh professor neil turock
friend of the show he is coming on soon
and he has the eponymous name of
of sir peter higgs from edinburgh
university so look for that episode
coming soon we're talking about his
models of the universe and the
astonishing simplicity of all things but
for now frank
thank you so much for joining us enjoy
the rest of your evening and i hope we
can talk again soon and thank you very
much uh for talking to me in oxford to
you in california by the great invention
tim berners-lee at cern came up that's
right that's right thank you so much
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you